[Música]
en Perú el presidente Pedro Castillo
rechazó la denuncia constitucional en su
contra y la calificó como un
quebrantamiento del orden constitucional
y democrático el mandatario también
solicitó a la oea la aplicación de la
carta democrática Interamericana pedido
que será debatido este jueves les
explicamos
queda poco más de 10 días para la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales en Brasil y los
candidatos se apresuran a conquistar
votos en el terreno de sus adversarios
el expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva sostuvo un encuentro con líderes
evangélicos un importante bastión de su
rival Yahir por sonar
la ciudad de Nueva York Busca asentar un
precedente en el trato hacia los
migrantes un nuevo centro con capacidad
para unas 500 camas abrió en la gran
manzana para dar respuesta al flujo de
personas enviadas desde los estados
fronterizos común
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Perú al presidente Pedro Castillo
rechazó la denuncia constitucional por
corrupción presentada en su contra la
semana pasada y denunció lo que calificó
como un quebrantamiento dolor de
constitucional y democrático el
mandatario ya había dicho que existía en
el país una nueva modalidad de golpe de
estado y por ello solicitó ayuda a la
oea que este viernes analizará el pedido
de aplicación de la carta democrática
Interamericana por parte de Castillo
escuchemos se está instrumentalizando
nuevas formas de torturas psicológica
con las detenciones preliminares y
presiones preventivas para conseguir
acusaciones contra mí y mi gobierno
en este contexto llamamos a las
organizaciones defensoras de los
Derechos Humanos para que intercedan
por los detenidos a quienes no se le
respeta el esencial derecho a la
presunción de inocencia y precisamente
para hablar de ese tema saludamos en la
capital canadiense a Salvador herencia
Carrasco les abogado y docente de la
Universidad de Ottawa ha trabajado como
asesor jurídico de la comisión andina de
juristas asesor jurisdiccional senior
del tribunal constitucional de Perú y
asesor jurídico del Ministerio de
Justicia y Derechos Humanos de Perú
Bienvenido a Francia 24 Salvador hay una
ruptura del orden democrático en Perú
según lo establecido en la carta
Interamericana
No necesariamente la carta democrática
Interamericana tiene una serie de
situaciones para ayudar a mantener y
preservar el institucionalidad
democrática lo que ha hecho el gobierno
peruano en estos en estos días ha sido
solicitar una una audiencia por parte
del Consejo permanente frente a lo que
se considera son ciertas actuaciones por
parte del Congreso y otras autoridades
que podría menoscabar la
institucionalidad democrática de acuerdo
a los artículos 17 y 18 la carta ahora
esta carta habla de un principio de no
intervención pero señala que podría
solicitar asistencia para preservar la
democracia Qué acciones Se podrían tomar
en este caso la reuniones de los
consejos permanentes de la oea podrían
ordenar visitas podrían ordenar informes
pero a su vez lo más importante es una
labor de mediación y hay que tener en
cuenta que en la historia del Perú la
oea jugó un papel muy importante la
transición democrática entre el régimen
de fujimori y el gobierno transición de
Valentín Paniagua Entonces tenemos una
una participación activa de la oea que
permitió una transición pacífica entre
un régimen autoritario a un régimen
democrático Salvador herencia Carrasco
abogado y docente de la Universidad de
Ottawa Gracias por acompañarnos aquí en
France 24 Muchas gracias cambiamos de
tema pero seguimos en Perú se
registraron al menos 21 muertos en
huánuco tras consumir alcohol
supuestamente adulterado con metanol una
sustancia tóxica que ya dejó 117
intoxicados y 54 muertos en Lima desde
septiembre motivo por el que las
autoridades están rastreando el origen
de la intoxicación Alba Santana nos
amplía
en las calles de huánuco Perú se
extiende un mal decenas de personas han
sido encontradas muertas el motivo haber
consumido un alcohol supuestamente
tóxico conocido como alcohol metílico ya
saben un operativo multisectorial ya con
la fiscalía la policía la municipalidad
la diresa huánuco y otras instancias
para poder hacer la toma de muestra de
estos locales donde expenden estos
digamos aguardientes no como es lo que
ya han identificado algunos de los
afectados fueron trasladados al hospital
Aunque la mayoría ya había fallecido
tras consumir la sustancia Y es que el
metanol es una versión tóxica del
alcohol que se usa industrialmente en
solventes pesticidas e incluso como
combustible su consumo produce síntomas
como dolor de cabeza vómitos visión
borrosa e incluso convulsiones pudiendo
desencadenar en coma y muerte y dejando
secuelas como ceguera con las personas
con problemas de alcoholismo como los
más afectados hasta el momento nosotros
lo hagan antes que ocurran tantos
decesos siempre hemos estado haciendo
algunas
requisas pero no han sido suficientes
todo esto se produce después de más de
110 intoxicaciones y más de 50 muertes
en la capital Lima razón por la que las
autoridades investigaron y retiraron dos
marcas de alcohol del mercado por
contener la sustancia
el Ministerio de salud de Perú informó
sobre la presencia de metanol en dos
marcas de bebidas alcohólicas ante ello
recomendamos a la población evitar su
consumo y autoridades sancionar a
quienes expendan estos productos ahora
las autoridades están rastreando todos
los posibles orígenes de las
intoxicaciones con pruebas que podrían
tardar semanas en identificar las
bebidas causantes a más de una semana de
la segunda ronda electoral en Brasil
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva se acerca a
un bastión importante de su rival
conservador el presidente Jair bolsonar
un encuentro con líderes evangélicos
sirvió para que Lula despejara varias de
las preocupaciones sembradas por
bolsonaro durante la campaña Omar esa
nos cuenta más en el siguiente informe
un guiño en el terreno donde es más
fuerte su competidor en la recta final
del proceso electoral de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva intenta el
acercamiento a los evangélicos el
colectivo de votantes donde es más
fuerte su rival en una carta abierta Se
compromete respetar la libertad de culto
expresa su admiración por la obra social
de la iglesia evangélica y da la
bienvenida a esta comunidad religiosa en
su gobierno de resultar electo; el
presidente Yair bolsonaro insistido en
que Lula perseguirá los cristianos como
lo han hecho según él otros gobiernos
autoritarios e izquierda y muchos de sus
seguidores evangélicos le creen
desde el gran apoyo que le damos al
presidente bolsonaro es por su
autenticidad por lo que es el expresa lo
que es y no es la marioneta de nadie
aprovechó una reunión con representantes
e iglesias evangélicas este miércoles
para responder algunas de las
preocupaciones sembradas durante la
campaña como la introducción de baños
unisex en las escuelas
tengo una hija una nieta y una bisnieta
solo puede haber salido de la cabeza de
Satanás la historia de los baños unisex
solo de ahí
los evangélicos constituyen un tercio de
la población brasileña y una fuerza
electoral en la que bolsonara encuentra
un poderoso bastión a menos de dos
semanas el balotaje las encuestas
revelan un leve fortalecimiento de la
opción del presidente un nuevo centro de
migrantes abrió en la ciudad de Nueva
York con capacidad de unas 500 camas al
establecimiento compuesto principalmente
por tiendas de campaña gigantes Busca
dar respuesta a la masiva llegada de
personas en los últimos meses impulsada
por el envío de autobuses desde estado
sureños más en el siguiente informe de
Natalia plazas
un nuevo centro de acogida de migrantes
Abre en Nueva York cuenta con unas 500
camas y sus instalaciones en tiendas de
campaña gigantes incluyen lavandería
alimentación y llamadas internacionales
con este centro de la ciudad pretende
sembrar un precedente en el trato a los
migrantes
Este es un momento histórico no hemos
visto algo así en la ciudad de Nueva
York durante casi un siglo espero que la
conclusión de todos ustedes sea que la
ciudad de Nueva York que está haciendo
todo lo posible para asegurarse de que
los solicitantes de asilo sean tratados
bien con dignidad y que su bienestar sea
lo primero y más importante el espacio
solo acogerá a Hombres solteros y los
albergará durante unos días mientras se
finalizan sus trámites o son enviados a
otras partes del país no hay límite para
el tiempo que las personas que buscan
asilo podrán permanecer en esta
instalación si podemos identificar A
dónde quiere ir la persona es llevarla
allí lo más rápido posible el centro ha
sido criticado especialmente por su
localización en una zona de difícil
acceso y con fuertes vientos que pueden
suponer unas difíciles condiciones para
los migrantes en invierno la apertura
del centro humanitario en randalls
Island se da en un momento de crisis
migratoria en la ciudad de Nueva York
después de que estado sureños
republicanos lleven meses enviando
autobuses llenos de migrantes desde la
frontera Sur esta afluencia ha puesto a
prueba la ciudad y llevó al alcalde
Erika Adams a declarar el estado de
emergencia a inicios de mes hasta que
este Informativo en francés 24 Gracias
por acompañarnos continúen con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]